all right
mosh rudolph jacob jimenez arjun
srivastava legendary one what's up
always good to see you
always good to see everybody how we
doing
oh gosh that's loud okay our our sound
works we figured that out
um cool this is the big one
oops hold on turn this down hey that's
awesome yeah
if you guys aren't subbed to cosmic
culture chris's channel my roommate's
channel and i'm also on that too i do
videos
you definitely should giving away shield
right now let me just make sure
everything's good with the stream
sounds like it's good
[Music]
uh
sounds like it's good right now all
right i'm finn's
mf nervous yeah we could see omega red
that i don't want to get people's hopes
up
uh sub x
matter mine we should all be asleep
right now well unless you're over in
europe right now then it's uh let's see
it's pretty early for you depending on
where you're at
yvonne what's up patrick david what's up
bart simpson
pranchu v ready yeah they are calling
this the best episode so we'll have to
see about that
um we're supposed to cry in this episode
right
i mean that's the whole deal is we're
supposed to cry in this episode i don't
i don't know to me the only thing that
i think could make us cry as captain
america returns
chris evans as captain america returns i
don't know
um maybe something with isaiah bradley
right in his past as captain america and
the way his
country treated him and put him in
prison and
um experimented with him on
um what time does episode air
um 25 minutes sometimes they're early so
so be on the lookout for that because
they are early sometimes let's see
let me just make sure hey mr anderson
everybody say what's up mr
mr anderson the best mod
he does an incredibly good job and he's
awesome
give it up for him uh how much time is
left for the episode i
have the episode has not started yet but
let's go ahead and check on that
wow that's loud okay let's turn that
down
hey trista janna thank you so much woof
it's 4 in australia dang
ah legendary one of the first like
always coming to clutch all right let's
see
no it's not out yet we still have just
these
few episodes just the four episodes
uh christian zeran cheb didn't miss
anything
but hello good morning if if it's
morning good night or
good pm actually it's am now
about 24 minutes till it starts 23 now
just changed
this is going to be um this is going to
be an episode i think
i i don't want to hype anything up um
because i don't really know who the
cameo is going to be
it looked like what's his name john
malkovich was
either the power broker or the person in
charge of the grc that we saw on that
new
tv spot that we got so
according to the screenwriter there's a
cameo
but it that person is different than the
power broker so
if we don't find out who the power
broker is in this episode or the next
i'm going to be very very upset because
that's like
a benefactor thing where it's like how
could you not tell us who it is like
and we're going to be talking about it
for so long but you know these these
connect to movies and stuff like that so
we'll have to see what happens 8 37 in
norway is that am
yeah it's gotta be am yeah where has
zemo gone i don't know
but i think he's gonna come back hope
bucky doesn't sacrifice himself i don't
think buggy's gonna
sacrifice himself uh i'm
if you follow me on instagram or twitter
i posted some photos of what i believe
is the final scene
the one where sam and bucky you know
they're like
browing it out sam has a shield maybe
bucky teaches him how to throw it a
little bit maybe they fight over
you know oh it should actually be mine
maybe bucky says and
sam's like yeah get out of here maybe
they have like a throwing competition or
something and then i think
they part ways same gets a shield
i don't i don't know whether he becomes
a new captain america or not
but i think that's the final i think
that's the final
the final episode and i think i don't
think either of them are going to die
i don't think that's going to happen
make sure everything's right at the
stream
yinkan do i think isaiah will die
um no i think that would be
tragic after what he's been through
after being in jail for
decades all because he wanted to serve
his country
after being experimented on turn into a
super soldier being kept in the dark by
his own country
experimented on by hydra but
at the hands of the us it would be so
tragic if he died
hey super chef lewis thank you so much
for that super chat
good morning from the uk we ready for a
blinder yeah i mean
i i don't know what to expect because
in one division we were so hype and i'm
responsible for that partly right
because i hyped it up a lot about what
could happen my crazy
imagination goes crazy so uh
my bad on that one so i've been trying
to keep it pretty chill
um on this one like i've been saying i
don't think the x-men will be introduced
in this series
i think they'll be set up i think a lot
of the stepping stones for their
introduction are set up
right now how much longer the episode
comes up
about 20 minutes let's uh
let's do a little refresh here
uh yeah so sometimes they come out a
little bit early
um we still have about 20 minutes left
though so
we'll see about that uh
also camilla it's not that hard
um
yeah if they do evans might be in a
flashback
that's possible it's definitely possible
you know
i definitely thought it was chadwick
until
um i can't remember who came out and
said it
one of the screenwriters i think uh
maybe a producer
they came out and said like you know we
wouldn't do that um
after his death uh they're still
honoring him
they're still mourning the loss of him
um
and i thought it was him until then uh
until they came out and said that
because the dorm elijah showed up
uh a lot of wakanda vibes and i thought
that would be
i thought it would be really cool um
i don't know how many people share my
opinion on that but i thought it would
be kind of cool to
maybe maybe see him one last time
um but i don't
i don't know how what his condition is
in because he was in chemo and all that
nobody knew about it like
really brave guy and he filmed a lot of
stuff while going through some treatment
so
i don't know yeah paul bettany i see
some people saying white vision
aust gallandale yeah white vision paul
bettany
paul bettany got us and i don't think he
meant to like
i don't think he meant to really get us
i think he was joking around and it
became like this big thing because
obviously we're gonna
go oh my gosh paul bettany said like
he's working with this like
actor that he's always wanted to work
with and like how are we supposed to
know he's talking about himself right i
mean
we'll see about that um hold on let's
let me check something real quick
do a little quick little google search
right here
let's see if anything has changed as far
as the episode
5 cast yet
nothing's changed yet so i'm trying to
see i was trying to see if maybe they
they put
um like an updated cats list
but uh captain ray thank you so much
love back to you um
this one's really baffled me guys i'm
not gonna lie like this one
um i don't know
because they said about the cameo they
said
it is not someone currently existing in
the mcu
right so anyone we've seen take off the
table right a lot of people are like oh
it's isaiah it's like well
i mean we've seen him um
so it can't be him right because we've
seen him um he exists he was
in episode two right that's when he was
introduced um
so it can't be him but they also said
this person is not going to be
in any upcoming marvel projects i don't
know if that means like
like really soon or if that means like
ever so that's a tough one
because
so okay so here's my true thoughts since
they said that about it
since they said this person they they're
not going to be in any upcoming episodes
there are not going to be any upcoming
projects they're not
going to be they haven't been in the mcu
so far this leads me
to believe that this character will die
because
if it's a big character you know
why would it not be in future marvel
projects
so my thought process is the reason
they're not any and it's a new character
right because
it's not the mcu yet they're introducing
this new character and then it's really
just going to be for
this episode or for these two episodes
so
i think the person died
or whoever this cameo is is going to die
right um
because that to me makes the most sense
of
you know how to explain what happened um
so yeah that's my thoughts um who it
could be
i have no idea um it would be so cool
so cool if it was a mutant of some sort
omega red or something right it would
just be it would just be so cool
um but again let's not get our hopes up
because of one division
and because i don't want to be the guy i
was from one division hyping everybody
up for this i take full blame for that i
think me and eric voss
who i love he's he's a great guy um
we talked about that a lot and and i and
to this day i'll still like
i look at the loki trailer and i say um
hello there's like the whole stained
glass
part of in one of the shots
and like loki's here somebody else is
here or like or two people i can't
remember
up top of my head and in the middle of
stained glass there's the devil on it
and i'm just kind of like
okay like and then you got agnes saying
the devils and the details
it's just kind of like what the heck
yeah i feel i feel like we were
unintentionally
let on if that's even a thing
i don't know i don't know if i if i'm
being honest like who would i like it to
be
i think i don't think it would make
sense but i'd like to see
deadpool like i think that would be
hilarious um i think it's way too
serious at this point in time
throughout the episode um i i think
his humor couldn't come into play and i
think they probably want to introduce
him in a pretty comedic way
so i don't think it's deadpool um
and that would go against whatever the
producer said where
haven't been seen yet excuse me and
they're not going to be in any future
projects
but and i'm not i'm not trying to like
call the producer alarms they could be
lying they couldn't be misleading this
is what marvel does they
they love to throw us off you know what
we expect they love to put fake things
in trailers
you know um yes
i see a few people asking i have a
discord server
uh is it in
let's go to youtube is it in the about
me
of my youtube channel
let's see yes
my discord is link is in the about me
section
of my youtube channels page so just go
to my page
click the tab on the top that says about
me
um is there a chance the cameo is a
power broker eddie and
bouchez and i'm so sorry if i did not
pronounce that right thank you so much
for that super chat
yeah there is a chance uh totally there
totally is a chance um
but i think there's two um i think they
were talking about a specific cameo
and then i think the power broker is
separate
i can't conjure up the exact quote in my
head
but but i think they did say that was
different
um dr zeigler thank you so much for that
super chat
hey did the did they say if the falcon
um soldier's happening at the same time
as westview anomaly
how come falcon and bucky didn't hear
about it this is actually after
this takes place right we're actually
not sure if this takes place
before at the same time right before at
the same time or right after
spider-man far from home this takes
place six months after
avengers end game one division i think
it was three right maybe the chat can
help me out i think they said it was
three
um so no ag what up
can't wait yeah this is uh this is an
exciting one
um out of all the ones
i've been looking forward to this one
the most because they've been talking
about it
so let's do a quick refresh here
and let's see
let's see if it's out because they've
been releasing them a little bit early
dang it i thought we had it nope
all right let's check let's make sure
some stuff is happening
all right all right all right let's do
it let's do it let's do it
everything looks good yeah let me guys
tell me in the chat who do you guys
think it's going to be
uh we have 11 minutes kind of
it'll probably come out a little bit
earlier um
so spam spin the chat who do you think
it's going to be don't spam don't don't
give them a strainer there's not a hard
time uh but yeah just put down below
who you think it's going to be
walker fight secret cameo i'm render
ready daniel diaz thank you so much for
that super chat yeah uh uh i'm
i'm stoked for the fight i got major
major captain america civil war vibes
from the trailer the tv spot that we saw
you know you don't want to do this yeah
we do like oh man
chills when bucky said that chills when
bucky said that
and i'm thinking we're gonna see it's
gonna be like
bucky and uh steve rogers captain
america versus iron man
it's gonna i think that's gonna be
probably pretty similar
no a.g crazy only two more episodes i
know man
it's uh i like that one division with so
many episodes um
i don't know what marvel's plan is
but but i hope there's a season two um
i i know i know
there's gonna link into the movie
somehow but i don't know
if i don't know if
whatever they are playing for the movies
is going to end in a good enough place
for them to
pick up with the show so let's see about
that
uh let's let's do a
let's do a refresh
oh it's up okay 61 minutes it's an
hour and one minute long all right
who's ready for this uh we're about to
start
let me get a timer up here
let's do this stop watch
all right who is ready to watch because
we're about to
we're gonna start in five four three
two one
i gotta do this
part was the cry part i think it was as
a bradley part and lamar hoskins part
oh we're back to the flex masters got
some help to even out the odds
what
dang she just activated something on her
phone
oh bar truck i'm only here to kill the
falcon
oh she's she's got all these people
involved look at that
well they are getting uh
followers
tonight we got a battle all of us
other new york
oh dang
grc is voting on some act
oh it would move refugees back home to
their countries dang
taurus called
well they found out that
he said sam said i'll take it from here
all right new york city
oh yeah grc
they're
they're showing they're voting on the
thing
so they're just voting right now on this
stuff oh that's a flag smasher
oh there the flags matches are basically
hydra they've like infiltrated the grc
look at these people
and here it is oh dang
there it is oh samson suit
what we got what are we getting what are
we getting
oh it's here we go here we go what we
got oh you're not gonna show us come on
dude oh sam looks like he's uh feeling
it
oh we got what we got what we got
dude they're gonna like end this episode
right now before all the stuff starts
happening i know it
i know it and that's it just ended
ah little uh underwhelming of an episode
i liked it a lot not the best one but i
did truly like it a lot
is there a post credit scene
yes there is maybe wait
post credit scene post credit scene oh
snap oh snap post credit scene post
credit scene
post credit scene hammering oh dang
oh it's john walker i know what he's
doing he's making a new shield
yes he is oh
that's kind of cool not gonna lie that's
pretty cool
oh is he gonna he's gonna put a star in
it yeah he is
dang
dang look at that oh
dang whoa
is there another post-credits scene
no no other post-credits scene
not gonna lie i like that post-credits
scene uh
i like that post credit scene i think
i think that was cool john walker making
his own
john walker making his own captain
america shield let's
get going with the
let's get into the zoom chat with
everybody
yeah yeah yeah come on log into my email
yeah yeah
man
man i uh
it was a good episode was not the best
episode
was a good episode
dang it was pretty intense like uh
it was pretty intense um
to talk about is this the story with
isaiah was intense and it's very similar
to how the story was in the comics
um the cameo was uh julia louise dreyfus
the person that came up to john walker
and gave gave him the card
that that was the cameo
so is sharon carter the power broker
this is something that i'm not sure
about
because the power broker was threatening
to kill
carly
i don't think
huh interesting i wonder how i wonder
how
yeah i'm so i my thoughts are like kind
of kind of kind of going well but yes
the cameo was
madame hydra um valentina
ah crap what's her last name dave uh
uh allegra day fontaine um
madame hydra i don't know what that
means uh
i'm gonna go ahead and say hydra still
out there
because that's what i'm thinking oh that
camera is way off hold on
hello people
yo
microphone netting sweet
well all right
what an episode boys
dude i this episode honestly best
episode like i agree i think this is the
best episode
brad i was talking about you earlier
yeah i was talking about this with you a
couple of days ago like dude
i was so worried that they were gonna
rush things
that they wouldn't have enough time to
really take their time
with
i thought the end credits was amazing
shout out to shuri
i thought that was crafting the new
suits
dude oh my god bro we'll talk about all
the wakanda stuff all
of that awesome wait real real we're
quick sorry because some people said
this did they at some point in time say
that black panther was dead
no i didn't think so yeah some people
were kind of saying that
that's what i thought some people were
saying in the chat they said steve was
gone
yeah they said they said steve was gone
yeah they said steve
that was interesting like
again brad like you said you made such a
great point like bro
if steve was alive and he was just like
a retired old man just like chilling
like dude they wouldn't say that bro
what's going on
i think he's dead dude but would they
really do that off screen
i mean it certainly sounds like it sam
said it twice
but but do we think that the fact that
they're
just saying he's gone and not dead means
something
you know what i mean i vote he's not
dead
he might be back in the in the in the
timeline he went to with sharon
but like he he he lived in his life
yeah i mean yeah i mean he's pretty old
how long does a super soldier live and
that's what i'm saying like peggy
he lived through peggy's life so he's
he's on his own so if anything
he would be with these guys because he
has nobody left
yeah that's true he would have
definitely like way outlived her
yeah true true 100
uh wow wow uh
so guys tj thank you so much how are you
feeling about this episode
yes i pissed out in the first time
nasty if hydra still around is that
means experience ever stopped like twins
i would say so man
i would say so and thanks for that super
chat so who was the cameo into sharon
against bucky and and sam
cameo was julia louise dreyfus
and um i think sharon
is and the cameo was madame hydra um
brandon pifer thank you so much for that
that donation as well it was madame
hydra was the cameo the person the lady
talking to john
yeah king jay thanks for that super chat
i don't know how she would
put her with thor oh my gosh dude i'm
this was
such a good episode this this honestly
changed everything for me
boys i gotta say this real quick there's
no freaking way
that they're in new york city and we
don't see spider-man
oh yeah i know that that makes you think
especially because
dude this is like this well okay wait
what well what
sorry sorry before you're good they said
this takes place six months after in
game he might be
in europe yeah he's in europe that would
line up that would line up if it's like
it's the exact same
right is it right well they said six
months after endgame but we know far
from home is six months after in-game we
don't know like
what date you know what i mean we don't
know exactly but i'm saying if they were
like we're not showing spider-man we'll
just say it's the same time you know
easy excuse for them
but that would be so cool
hey but they did say they did say uh tom
apparently had like other cameos
no way no way no way no way we see no
way we see spidey but that's
one thing that like that's one of
marvel's biggest problems moving forward
uh vinnie thanks for that super chat am
i the only way to think sam and bucky
gonna die um
i'm sure you're not alone but i
personally don't think they're gonna die
so like yeah daredevil so dude like
there's so there's there's so much and i
love
dude i love the way this episode set up
the finale because
first of all that scene of buckingham
training
that's not the final scene of the show
no i was yeah i was wrong i was telling
everybody i was
wrong about that i definitely thought it
was the final thing dude
[Applause]
they did a great job like hiding the
fine that like the final app
episode like i have that's true yeah
like that's true i have no clue what's
going on we've only seen anything john
walker walking down the street all
pissed off with his new shield i think
it's kind of cool how he like embedded
his medal of honor and stuff like that
that was pretty cool so wait okay wait
what was my thought
was my thought wasn't my thought wasn't
without i had a big thought oh it's
sheriff carter the power broker
she can't be yeah she can't be in here
they give her that one quick scene
that like had no significance to like
anything going on in this episode
whatsoever she's up to something
yeah she can't be the power broker the
power broker wants to kill carly right
that's what i was thinking
and and she wouldn't be helping them out
she had contact just like oh here's
here's where they're at he's been saying
this whole time or she's been saying
this whole time
i'm gonna find you and i'm gonna kill
you well she did say
last episode he's pit or he wants the
serum back
so maybe it is a guy right so a guy in
my uh
a chat helmet helm litmus
brought up a good point that she's not
using an apple phone
and apple doesn't let anybody use their
phones for the villains
so because she has an android she's a
bad guy oh that's
funny nah nah another thing i wanted to
say too is that
very interesting scene they they capped
off zemo's story in this episode
with the wakandans bro yeah ayo
mentioned
ayo mentioned she told bucky like uh
something along the lines of like yo
like you need to come to wakanda we we
could we could use you as the white wolf
dude i think it's so possible we see
bucky in black panther too
i think i i thought she said don't come
to wakanda that's what i thought she was
saying i think she said she said steer
clear she said she said i thought she
said come to wakanda no i think she said
stay away she said don't like don't come
to plunder they pissed at you for
letting zma
right yeah that's what i heard too never
mind
and then he said like noted like all
right
kind of like oh crap yeah boys
very very suddenly in this episode
taurus is going to become falcon
as he does in the comics oh yeah yeah
that's great detail
great detail as he does in the comics
and he's gonna fix him up that's a good
call man exactly
yeah how about just playing catch with
the captain america's shield
dude it was really cool to see sam like
learning how to do it
yeah that was super super cool yeah like
throwing it missing it not you know not
catching
stuff like that
uh bradley jones thanks so much for that
super chat the case
was the new captain america suit for sam
that shuri
made falcon uh
so that's gonna be really cool to see oh
okay okay this is a great cause someone
in my chat
sent in a super chat and said sharon was
on the phone with bad truck
because they had some type of yeah yeah
they were speaking french well that was
well that was bad track at the end too
who yeah and he sent them to the flex
match to the flagship sharon can't be
the power broker sharon is working with
backtrack yeah
and he must be who she led out of jail
she said i let you out of jail right
she's helping he's helping her steal all
these paintings she's selling to get
rich
yeah so it's interesting man how does
she fit into all of this
i don't know i'm completely confused i i
think
i think she went to madrid
did what she had to do she kind of
knew things like you know bar tracked a
leaper and everything like that
and kind of you know she she said in the
interview
emily van hack that you know sharon
you know there is no kind of loyalty
left for her america
essentially betrayed her right you know
so
does she does she care anymore i i don't
know if she has any loyalty
i don't buy that guys i really don't
know well i i so i do think so
that would go against everything peggy
stood for
that's true too like she went into that
line of work because of peggy
i just don't i don't see her like
yeah what happened to her sucks but kev
i agree and thanks for that super chat
but the problem is is the power broker
wants to kill the flag smashers
so i don't it's hard to tell if she is
but i don't think she is
part of the entire show like that's
probably one of the biggest questions
we've had
with this entire series yeah
yeah yeah it's going to be interesting
to see how she plays a role in this
final episode
because chandler
i understand your pain thanks for that
super chat uh they they kept it for the
very last episode
uh we haven't seen any scenes of it yet
so we're gonna have to
we'll see thanks for that super chat
helping bucky with his like mental
health and ptsd dude
america captain and captain america as
hell 100
yeah and he said it he's like uh steve
is gone
right yeah but even if he was here like
it doesn't matter what he said he has to
say or something like that well that's
kind of a theme
kind of going back to what you said brad
like kind of a theme is kind of like
you know because sam is like isaiah did
this but i'm going to do this because
i understand where isaiah's come from
but that's not me i mean and
then you know them saying the same thing
like you know it doesn't matter what
steve thought right because you're you
ig i mean it could very well go the same
with sharon carter like yeah you're
you're on it's peggy but you're sharing
carter and you know you gotta do what
you gotta do
i think she's good i think she was
hustling around because she had to
and i think she had some type of
connection with the power broker
doing work for him something like that
but i don't think she was power breaker
and i think she'll i don't think she is
anymore hold up boys
someone just made a great point in my
chat zemo they made it they made a point
to say that zemo isn't going to wakanda
he's going to crash yeah he is going to
the rafters who runs the raft
ross ross thunderbolts baby thunderbolts
yep it's happening hey coming disposed
yeah
it wasn't my favorite episode going to
admit to that i'm not as
jacked up about it as uh as supes is
um everyone's a top their own opinion
but it wasn't my favorite it's probably
not the worst episode maybe
the second and i still liked it and i
think it had a lot of great
what parts but i think so super chat
walker scrap metal shield won't hold up
the fights in new york maybe luke cage
will be the character appear in episode
six oh that would be cool
um yeah i don't know what the heck he
was saying with his shield it's not
vibranium by any means
thanks for that super chat it would be
cool to see uh nemo
i mean maybe he's read hulk some of the
characters from black widow are all
options as well it'll be an incredible
team
yeah that's gonna be so much cool so
much fun to and cool to see the
no it's to be so much cool so much cool
to see that thunderbolt
boys let's talk about that mystery cameo
battle hydra
because i have no idea madam hydra
madame hydra that's who that is
i had no clue well i it's so i'm so
stupid i caught i was like i look tina
fey at first
and then thankfully mr anderson my
moderator was like it's julia louise
dreyfus i'm like oh yeah that's that's
what i meant
valentina fontaine
uh madame hydra yeah call me valor don't
call me about whatever she said
um madame hydra so hydras
still here still alive i mean that's not
a surprise though right well you cut off
one head three more grow back right you
know what's the same yeah right
so um oh
okay uh it just dropped
i think that she was the i think that
she was thank you to him
yeah uh z omg it's john
would have to rewatch the scene but when
sharon was on the phone there was a guy
standing in the showers in the
background power broker oh
thanks for that super chat yeah we're
gonna have to i'm gonna have to check
that out maybe maybe
three three nine three okay so i'm
guessing sam got his captain america's
suit
but who was the big cameo like anyone
know who was like yeah it was a lady who
was talking to john walker
after he got out of the court um madame
hydra
could doom thank you for that super chat
because sharon b setting up flag smashes
with battle truck
she did set them up uh
didn't beltron get hired by fury and
winter soldier
oh man i don't remember oh man i don't
know
jack hey sorry man yeah i've been really
bad at the messages i'm so sorry about
that but hey thanks so much for that
super chat
uh i'm gonna just hit you up right now
on the insta's
am i not getting messages from you i
don't i don't have any messages from you
there we go gotcha i hit you up thanks
man
all right i need thoughts on how did
this wrap up we got one episode
i'd love to hear your theories jack what
are you
new york it's gonna be guys epic island
fan 20. i think the heart-shaped urbans
of the box oh dude that would be really
cool
oh wow thanks for that super chat was
julia hillary street is supposed to be
the big cameo yes pirate man and thank
you for that super chat she is madame
hydra
dsg good bar thanks for that super chat
does fontaine mean leviathan replacing
yeah
because she is part of leviathan in the
comics yeah i mean
i don't even maybe hey fabian thanks
super chat
yeah they yeah like uh
chris or brad said they've done a great
job at
really not showing us any of the final
episode
i mean i'm trying to think just captain
not captain america well it's called
captain america just john walker
uh walking down the street with the
shield on
um which by the way
that shield's not gonna hold up
and it's going to like fly off you're
going to tell me
that's vibranium right no there's no way
it's but there's
zero chance it's vibranium i mean
uh lucky's gonna smash through that
thing yeah yeah it'll be interesting to
see that
yeah oh so so uh someone in the super
chat brought up a pretty
pretty cool thing that uh allen fan 20.
i think the heart-shaped herb
is in the box that they gave sam which i
think would be really
cool um it would be like so
because that would be like hey i'm a
super soldier like captain america was
but not really because i
that'd be super cool but i feel like
that's such a sacred what khan did
yeah i don't yeah no yeah i don't i
don't think it's gonna happen but what a
cool thing if it did
who's who's shipping bucky and sarah
because i am
we got those vibes
thanks don't yeah that's funny
that was fun i was like i was like
they're flirting a little bit
don't follow my sister dude another sam
dropped the super chat in
and he said that um and the secret
invasion comic
um contessa de la fontaine which was
that character that came out in today's
episode
valentina uh yeah yeah valentina de la
fontaine
has been replaced by a scroll spy and is
trying to find fury
so this all could be leading up to
secret invasion that's true too because
yeah obviously
that that's coming so is there
any chance that from some random contact
while john walker was on tour
his shield is made of adamantium no way
no he he can't see he seemed to be
gathering scrap metal
yeah no chance yeah yeah i wouldn't say
no chance but very very slim because
that that cause
he's making a shield that's got to do
something right
if they've gone through all the work of
making a shield
that obviously is not going to be
stronger than vibranium they can't
pretend it's stronger than vibranium
if it's just iron or you know pick a
metal
i've just i mean i think it's gonna i
think it's gonna get scrappy fast with
walker as it did in this opening fight
yeah he wasn't he he he barely he almost
barely got to use the shield in this
fight
just because he was up in close close
quarters combat
bucky and sam were rushing him and i
think it's gonna be the same with with
the flag smashers because they they
don't have like any rage attacks
uh armando the odin poorest of the box
that's hilarious
thank you for the super chat uh abatron
d11 what are the girls who talked to
walk could be the power broker well
she's madame hydra
uh in the comics so i i don't know if
she would actually be the power broker
at the same time
how do you think zemo would react to
mutants sneaker project thanks
thanks thanks for those yeah uh given
everything he's
against he's probably not gonna really
really like mutants
bartracht was hired by fury to take over
the boat and winter soldier flush out
the bad suits from the world security
council sharon double agent oh
maybe alma i'm a pal thanks for uh
thanks so much for that super chat emma
murdock wasn't there someone in 1940s
that was named sarah and that's why
bucky was vibing with her
i'm not sure about that but thank you so
much for that super chat i can't recall
okay so um i got a super chat
and i i can't remember but it says bar
truck was hired by fury
to take over the boat in winter soldier
to flesh out the bad seeds from the
world security council
so maybe sharon's a double agent hey
now we're talking
oh [ __ ] i don't know
is there a reason why sharon would want
falcon dead other than her life's been
terrible for the last six seven years
no no no right now she'd just kill him
i feel why put it why put him through
all of it and risk
the flag smashers being taken down when
you could just kill him
that's why it's so weird that like that
connection i just don't follow it
it's gonna be very interesting to see
that pays out and i really hope it does
i hope it's not some huge cliffhanger
but
yo boys another thing that threw me off
with this cameo is um
malcolm spellman said that the cameo
would be a character that he really
wants to see paired up with thor
yeah i don't made zero sense i don't get
that that's what really threw me off
yeah i i don't i don't get that at all
and
if she is madame hydra or an actual
character didn't they say that she's not
going to be
in any of the upcoming stuff
am i wrong about that i mean variety
legit
just dropped this article saying that
she was supposed to be a black widow and
she
she's gonna be appearing in more stuff
oh okay well
screw me maybe it's the power broker
maybe it's the power broker cameo
because they did say that
didn't they say that they were different
that the cameo isn't the power broker
because why would she be the power
broker and madame hydro like right i
mean
i don't think it's the power broker
unless they're gonna yeah i was gonna
say unless they're really gonna say that
oh no
she's not madame hydra she's
powerbreaker
chandler um thanks for that super chat
i don't i don't i think he'll come back
maybe in the thunderbolts maybe not
hydra
uh usmc private gomez
one thanks for that super chat i super
appreciate it darius woods what if super
solid serum worked
on isaiah bradley because he's the
wakandan descent pretty sure the
heart-shaped herb
herbs in the original serum interesting
i'll have to
do some research about that definitely
have to
do some research about that thank you
for that super chat marvel doesn't do
anything
um matt hutch thanks for the super chat
theory bedroom hydra puts the
thunderbolt together
yeah i hope so man i i i really hope so
seven pop tarts things that superset you
upset
that i wasn't the special cameo ah thank
you
i uh i wish i was maybe the suitcase was
dark wins costume from invincible
thank you i have a tron for that super
chat was walker shield from scrap metal
or vibranium jabber 27 thank you i think
it was from scrap metal i i really do i
don't think he could have gotten my
brain in anywhere
surround parmar
power broker develop task master
yeah i i think so that would be really
cool
doom another super chat thank you so
much what's up [ __ ] you son they showed
it break or some short circuit never
bring it back
also second time's art failed yeah i'm
not sure
i think maybe because it's like the like
you know metal conducts electricity
maybe it just
messed them up joaquin fernandez
sees broken shield from in game is still
out there maybe that becomes john shield
and thunderbolts oh that would be pretty
cool
thank you for that super chat a tallow
de paulo
that sounded john walker making the
shield was very iron man yeah it was
it's very for
that's a foreshadow i think spiderman
will be a cameo next week that would be
pretty cool
and it is in new york it is in new york
hey clint 2220 thank you so much that's
a great
there that's a generous super chat with
the fight probably occurring there in
new york possible
strange came out instead of multiverse
madness yeah i think they might try to
keep it a little bit more grounded
but uh totally possible maybe doctor
strange maybe spider-man
isaac growl man thank you so much the
super chat sharon carter was also
captain america at one point in the
comics
so she could be powerbooker trying to
get a working serum maybe that's could
totally be possible
bro yeah i i think the power broker
could be ross and he could you know be
setting up the thunderbolts i
maybe maybe madame hydra since you know
ross isn't
you know he's a little shady he does
some bad things right you know
for sure maybe he's working with her
maybe he's hydra
this whole time you know you never
really know and maybe maybe they set up
the thunderbolts
uh you know john walker becomes part of
it uh
boys we still got i'm pretty sure we got
another post-credits scene next episode
oh for sure for sure yeah they have to
like i'm predicting
uh thunderbolt ross is confronting zemo
about the thunderbolts
yeah i would i would i mean this really
does feel like we have a few characters
here
that could be thunderbolts and
i i really hope that happens like i i
really really hope that happens
my boy caden brings up a pretty cool
point here he said the main dude at raft
is ross
right which we know we've talked about
already yeah he thinks at the end of the
show
we're gonna see john walker end up there
task master master might end up there
yeah
yeah cause this technically yeah we're
gonna see
we're gonna see ross going through like
he's at walmart just picking
bro i'll take you you let's go do this i
was about to say that because black
widow was supposed to come out before
falco before
yeah yeah yeah so he might have to end
jail and exactly and we know ross plays
plays a pretty significant role in the
black widow movie right yeah multiple
different times yeah
and we're gonna see what happens with
taskmaster in that movie but
i think we all know that taskmaster has
to be a part of the thunderbolts just
because he's such a badass
and we got we gotta see more of it one
movie yeah i 100 agree so yeah he'll
probably be in the raft
he's probably there already he is there
he's there already
he's there already he's totally there
already
[Music]
alba powell again thank you so much
sharon is
in the daughter's liberty in the comic
books the woman hero group it's kind of
obscure
but could be a startup for the new
series
possibly and given how progressive
marvel's been lately
that makes sense i'm trying not to miss
super chats
clint thank you so much for that super
chat clint 2 2 again big super chat also
what's y'all's idea of the power broker
and shay teen 10 race connection the
series cap fire
i don't think it's going to connect i
think everything will connect but
i don't think that for jordan parish i
don't know if y'all touched on this but
a mix of this classic suit for sam
some vibranium tech we've seen black
panther thank you for that super chat
yeah i think that's what we're going to
see i think it's going to be pretty dang
awesome
pretty dang awesome dude it reminds me
of the enemy
it reminds me of the end of the amazing
spider-man 2 where that like mysterious
guy is just
walking through the chamber and you see
the the cases
uh you've all reuben route that's pretty
cool
but if sharon uses the flag smashers but
trades them experiments on thumb to get
the serum and give it to ross in
exchange for a pardon
i think that could happen i think that
could happen
i'd like to see bucky break red wing now
i'm patron thank you super chat that'd
be funny
uh usmc private gomez
one what samsung gonna look like do you
think someone else is gonna become
falcon yes i think torres is gonna be
joaquin taurus gonna become falcon thank
you so much for the support
um there's been some leaks of it
and like toys and stuff uh so you can
find those online if you want to be
spoiled
but you can you can see if you really
want to want to see
uh aiden g what if the kind of box has
energy wings
from the more modern falcon costumes
that would be pretty cool and
and and since since they are vibranium
they can't absorb energy and then
release it so it'd be cool
so many different directions marvel can
take us i wonder where they'll go
one more episode left boys well i'm
really excited to see
[Music]
sam's suit i wanna i can't believe they
didn't show it to us like show
it i knew that no i knew they weren't
gonna shut up
turn the camera i knew they weren't
gonna choice but
when he appeared like when we first when
we first see him next episode
what an entrance i know yeah that's
gonna be so cool
captain america ladies and gentlemen
does he have that's how they started off
him wearing it and he just shows up
wearing it do you think he
do you think it has wings oh yeah it
does i think it hasn't oh yeah for sure
yeah i mean he has wings with his when
he's falcon america in the comics
right no i don't i think he should not
do the suit looks amazing so so
is it vibranium right i mean it's got to
be like a black panther
suit right i mean like
it can absorb energy and then release it
and start like
oh yeah it'll be top of the line yo okay
sorry this just reminded me of this
back in the beginning yo john walker
almost beat him that was pretty cool
it was really awesome it was such a
great thing yeah duty
and it's crazy because like like i felt
like
one of my biggest uh i guess fears going
into that battle was that they were
going to nerf
bucky because like bucky was dude and
what's your soldier buckingham was still
got cap
so like i i i really i was but
it really didn't feel like they nerfed
bucky like him and him and walker were
going back and forth yeah
and walker was taking them out in very
creative ways
i don't i don't know if they were in i
don't think they were intentional
but like using the environment where
like he knocked bucky back and then
bucky got electrocuted
uh yeah obviously he's gonna he's gonna
kick sam's butt because sam isn't a
super soldier and he's just he'll
overpower him
with when it comes to just raw strength
well that's where they do because
uh a flower from wakanda that's what i'm
saying like
because that would be a really cool
twist right i know i don't have the
super soldier serum i have the
heart-shaped herb you know like
that which is so cool i feel like
jack thanks again for another one uh
super chat power brokers mutant from
magic
power brokers the pawn of ross has uh
muted the magi board descent ever been a
thunderbolt ah
yeah i don't know the magic port is sent
mutant yes a magic border set not sure
i'll look into that
joshua lalaberte took several the
avengers to even begin melting old terms
vibranium age of alternatives away
walker
did welding vibranium no yeah i agree
and thank you for that
it's not vibranium or adamantium i don't
think it can
darken story 15 madam hydra val is to
fall into valkyrie with thor oh maybe
hmm i think he's a super chat that's a
good thought
and he will always get back up because
he can do this all day maybe yeah
maybe maybe carly has
one left back and she gives it to him i
don't think he'd take it i don't know
that he would but you it
brings up a really good point though
it's like if he's gonna be cap he's got
to be able to be
cat yeah he's not going to beat john
walker he took the shield from him but
that doesn't mean he beat
john walker right and it goes back to
what oh
erskine said with the serum yeah yeah
good becomes great
badminton's worse well and and
if it like if it was bucky one-on-one or
falcon 101 again
against john walker walker would have
beat him i mean it was
both of them i mean he really john
walker has been training his whole
life for that moment exhaustively dude
up on on the super soldier serum perfect
i i thought it was really really really
cool
when he was in court and he's like you
made me this
like it was so cool bro no hold up for
him this was the best acted
episode by wyatt russell like his
performance in this episode i could give
him that scene oh yeah
i can give him that that that was real i
really really liked that
that was really cool walking away while
they're still talking to him kind of
like i don't
care you're lucky john and chuck's like
yeah i'm so lucky
that was so cool i loved that that was
great episode
great episode boys but i gotta get out
of here yep
same people we gotta go to work awesome
awesome
next season finale baby finale next week
this chat's gonna be
let's go guys come back next week for an
even crazy finale
all of the boys are gonna be back we're
gonna be talking about this
the next time we talk it'll be it'll be
after the finale after the finale next
time we'll be after the finale
we'll all be sitting there with a moment
of silence for the end of the season too
yeah i know jesus dang it
well all right boys see you after the
finale
brad porn wow okay
uh i have super chats to get to don't
worry i will get to them i am so sorry
just had to say goodbye uh megan
drummond
sam is not in the footage of the fight
where we have seen bucky slash capped
not really the suit yep makes a ton of
sense and it makes sense the suit is
wakanda tech to make up for no super
solid serum yeah because i i i'm not
sure that if they gave him a serum he
would take it after
everything you know after everything
that they talked about
uh okay super chat super chat super chat
super chat
uh jp 3393 bucky asked the favor and
then brought that case yep
that's yeah so man i i
is it gonna be like you know the black
panther suit like
just with captain america symbol on it
is it going to be
able to absorb energy and then release
it like uh t'challa you know i'm super
excited to see that
that's going to be cool uh there's one
more super chat
tj lewis thanks thinks that super isaiah
bradley help in final battle
that's a tough one i think he's done
maybe there's some um like behind the
scenes
like conversation between sam and him
that we didn't see
that might resonate with him and then
when he sees the battle in new york he
shows up there's a possibility that
could happen
um off the top of my head i want to say
no i want to say
i want to say he's out like he did his
part he did his
fight he he was treated very unfairly
and
i mean more than that obviously right we
heard the story and he's done
you know he was even it was it was kind
of crazy when he said
you know what did he say like no
self-respecting black man would want to
take the shield after everything that's
been done you know
um so i mean
i don't know if he gets in the fight i
don't know if he gets in the fight
i i i i don't i don't think he does
uh josiah sama
just finished episode everyone seen in
credit scene this time yes uh
and i thought it was pretty cool uh john
walker
he is crazy uh refusing to not you know
even in the court here and he was like i
am captain america
and he walked away and
he was probably treated pretty unfairly
there
uh he he he probably was um
i mean the flax smashers are killing
people
and they are terrorists like
they're doing a really good job of like
making them relatable right because they
believe they're doing a good cause which
you know there's a lot of bad
organizations out in the real world who
believe that they're actually doing you
know like a good cause and stuff like
that
so they're they're humanizing her and
the flag smashes in a way
that makes you like kind of like them
but they are terrorists they're killing
people
um that's just how it is um
stephanie diaz thanks for that super
chat would madam hydra have some
connection with the cosmic cube if so
isn't that part of jane foster storyline
oh yeah that's a great
way to connect it back to what the
malcolm spellman was saying about
seeing them together with thor i i'm not
sure if it was
malcolm spellman or another screenwriter
um
that's a good connection and thank you
for that super chat i'm trying to think
of just
how much
i don't think she's good um
and i'm kind of wondering
the tesseract is connected to loki loki
is connected to the thor i'm just trying
to put the pieces together i think
you're on to something there
um
hydra itself has a big connection to the
cosmic cube
and there was a leak wow that was loud
there was a leak that said something
like there are remnants
of the cosmic cube uh
slash tesseract that
some people are like studying like
energy and stuff like that so
there could be a connection there i like
where your head's at thank you for that
super chat
um
yeah so for people asking the cameo was
julia louise dreyfus
um that can be a pretty underwhelming
cameo if you don't know who she is
um she was on seinfeld uh
so the seinfeld fans definitely knew who
she was i called tina fey at first
that's my bad
um she's madam hyder in the comics
i don't know what implication
i don't know what implications that has
for the future
of the mcu i'm gonna say hydra still
around and
i don't think she's the power broker
it would be really weird
it would be really weird if she was
because like she's madam hydra so they
would basically be saying like
well i mean i guess she could be i hope
she's not i hope we haven't seen the
power broker yet and i hope it's a big
thing
maybe it's like so big that they don't
even reveal it until the post-credits
scene in fact now that i think about
that
now that i think about that we might not
see the power broker till the
post-credits scene
of the finale that might be the reveal
that connects this show to
whatever movie or show that it's going
to connect to you know um
that might be what happens uh
yeah which is fine as long as they
reveal who he is
right i mean i i don't want to go
through the finale through its
post-credit scene and everything
and not find out who the power broker is
that's
that's just going to make me mad um
sell sodi or selaya sodi i'm sorry for
pronouncing wrong
so who's teaming up at the final battle
sharon harder bar truck to work with
carly
john walker prob is more against carly
than sam but same as shield
yeah it is quite a little bit of a bunch
of stuff going on there thank you for
that super chat um
i don't i think i think john walker is
crazy
right now um
he had to try and be
captain america steve rogers without a
super soldier serum
and the reason steve was kind of chosen
as
captain america was because of who he
was his moral and his ethics and it's
something that i don't think john could
live up to
i mean clearly as we've seen he can't
and um
i think a lot of this is driving same
crazy then his best friend died and then
his
you know his best friend's parents he
lied to them and told them yeah you know
i killed the person who killed him
so that's why he's really going after
carly i think so i think his main focus
is carly
i think sam to him would be
collateral damage and i think he'd kill
him if he got the chance
you know um but i think his main focus
is going to be going after carly
i think sam's main focus is going to be
going after carl and he's going to have
to kind of deal with walker
uh you know at the same time and kind of
just like dude get out my way maybe
fight a member you know here and there
but uh
um i think his shield's gonna
fail drastically i don't even know what
uh
i i don't even know what he's thinking
about that shield we'll have to see
numerole productions it's official
mickey mouse's power broker
we got it we got it right there thank
you for that super chat
um malek shepard yes i
uh i probably am going to see more to
come at yes
uh kev 5857
what marvel project is coming out after
falcon winter soldier
besides the assembled since loki is
coming out in june uh black widow
uh oh wait did they move the release
date dang it when is black widow coming
out
black widow i can't remember when it was
it's may right
oh no they moved it to july um
yeah i'm not sure there is one in
between i think we might have a little
bit of a break there
yeah i think we might have a little bit
of a break there uh
just kind of sad because well i mean
we go like 2020 nothing at all right and
then we get like all these projects back
to back to back to back to back
um it's kind of nice i think we're kind
of a little spoiled but from
if you think about it moving forward
i think marvel's doing like three disney
plus shows a year
and three movies a year uh more
depending right now they're kind of all
squinched together because of the
pandemic and everything like that
so but i think we can plan on three
movies and three disney plush shows a
year which is
a lot of awesome content especially
because the the series you know they're
uh you know six episodes long nine
episodes long five episodes however long
they're going to make all these ones
right so i think uh i think it's pretty
cool
free like there's never been a better
time to be
you know marvel fan like we all are so i
think i think that's pretty pretty cool
um
um
i i i'm trying to wrap my head around
sharon carter in this whole
situation i i don't think she's the
power broker
because i do think the power broker
wants
uh carly and the flag smashers dead
um
i'm trying to figure out her connection
to
uh i'm really trying to figure out her
connection to flag smashers and
but i don't know i i'm like really
trying to figure out what this all means
uh k5857 unless that's when they're
going to release trailer like shane chi
or maybe spider-man just to
have he's talking maybe i don't know
yeah um thanks for that
another super super super chat yeah um
that would be nice of them to do uh i
don't know if they would do that
but it would be nice of them to put out
trailers and stuff you know we don't
have the internals australia yet
shang chi trailer and sima leo has been
like sitting
on it like been talking about basically
like wanting to uh
release it so um
sharon carter carter is uh
it's she's it's racking my brain i think
she
i stated in a few videos that i've done
so far since like we've seen her i think
she
is somehow working for thunderbolt ross
um in an effort to try and get
pardoned to come back home why
ross would want the flag smashers
to be in power maybe she's betraying the
flagship i just
it's uh it's really kind of like
wrapping
warping my brain like i can't wrap my
head a brown um
evan mosser thanks so much for the super
chat is the scene with isaiah bradley
confirmation of the weapons plus
program in the mcu um
uh yeah um we've already had the
confirmation of the weapons plus program
in the mcu
in the incredible hulk uh thunderbolt
ross
one of the what do you call it
containers that like the serum was in
that he made abomination from said the
said weapons plus on it
um now if we're talking weapon x with
striker
i i think a lot of these major poor
talks and connections and stuff like
that are gonna
are are a big connection to that
um the outcast kid thanks for that super
chat
could sharon be connected to norman
osborne could he be the dark horse
and credits cameo and if thunderbolts
we see ghost batman again yeah i think
uh ghost from antman would be a really
good
character for the thunderbolts um and
i've always kind of talked about in some
videos where
i've theorized and guess what the team
could be i've always
tried to put her in it because i
actually do think she'd be a pretty good
thunderbolts character
um she was a
villain but i'm not sure if my only
concern about that is i don't know if
anybody knows who she is because she's
wearing the mask and everything like
that
i mean thunderbolt ross probably would
right uh so
yeah um so she totally could be and then
you have zemo
and since the raft is ran by thunderbolt
ross um that's what we saw in civil war
um there's gonna probably be taskmaster
there
and i think like we were talking about
in the discussion i think um
thunderbolt ross can have a lot of
people to choose from let's let's let's
put it that way
um sorry guys this was a good episode
it had a lot of good parts to it wasn't
my favorite episode
but i i i loved it nonetheless
um a lot of dialogue
and the acting was really good um
but i think next episode i'm hoping
there's going to be a lot to it so
uh we'll see we'll see i'm going to ask
that super chat stop now because i'm
about to get off and there is a little
bit of a delay
um so i don't want to miss any super
chat
so let's do no more super chats we'll be
back next week having a big conversation
uh we'll talk before the finale we'll
watch it together
um then we'll talk after the finale do
the the
excuse me and then we'll do the um
discussion like we always do i'm excited
to see what's gonna happen
bad batch between falcon the winter
soldier and loki matt hutch thank you
for that super chat yeah uh we have star
wars the bad batch coming out
um i was trying to i was trying to think
just marble but yeah there is stuff in
between but marvel
i don't think they're in it there is a l
thank you for that super chat
power broker is most likely the military
guy sharon is enabling the flag smashers
which will
push the patch act good thought
uh yeah yeah um
uh the only
concern and reservation i have about
that is i
i i want it to be somebody we haven't
seen yet i want another cameo from
somebody you know what i mean
um i want it to be surprising
um
so i hope that's not the case because i
i want more
than that uh
i want more than that so all right guys
i got some work to do
it's gonna be a long night i'm gonna do
my indian explain video
and talk about uh you know some theories
that that i think
is uh that i think are going on i have
to watch it again
kind of capture my thoughts on this and
uh do that and then saturday's gonna be
my full breakdown of everything where i
look for easter eggs and
connect everything explain it down in
the simple terms you know for people who
don't look as deep as some of us do um
so look out for that in
it's uh it's later 2 30 now
um i'd say like
five yeah like five hours look out for
my engine explained video and my
theories and stuff like that
um
they said some stuff that i'll go over
in my video so um
did i miss did i miss a super chat
no i didn't so for those of you i see
some people asking the cameo was julia
louise dreyfus
um the woman who went up to john walker
when he was after the trial when he was
with his wife she gave him a card
said nothing on it um
she is madame hydra in the comics which
is interesting because it means hydra
still alive so that was cameo
a little underwhelming i would say but
um
it's interesting to think that hydra
still around so i i like it in that
sense um
i definitely like it in that sense so
the next one the next finale the finale
is the next episode
only one episode left it's going to be a
big battle in new york
um sam's going to get his captain
america to put it on what kind of
technology it's gonna
be it's gonna be cool
yeah so the box that the box that uh sam
was giving at the end is his new captain
america suit's gonna have vibranium
wings i'm sure
and a really cool suit um i'm looking
forward to seeing sam and that
and him becoming the new captain america
which i hope he does
so all right guys i'm getting off got
lots of work to do
um big shout out to mr anderson for
being an awesome moderator
again uh thank you so much shout out to
everybody who did the super chats i
super appreciate it and of course
everybody showed up i love you all you
guys are awesome um these are fun every
week they're fun because of you
uh oh wait last super chat dan
dan from pensacola florida which is
where i was born uh i got five bucks
that carly blows up that butt oh
no that would be so that would be so bad
no
i don't want that no no no no no no no
no no i don't i don't want that at all
oh that would be so sad
don't be so sad don't be so sad but uh
we'll see right i just i hope not
that would be really sad especially
after i decide not to sell it so
i i don't think she's gonna harm sam's
family i think she kind of likes sam
uh but we'll see hey um sorry guys
i'm gonna get to work i'm still kind of
baffled about who the power broker is
and
what sharon cardo's role is uh
but i'll gather my thoughts and uh i'll
have a video out in about
five hours so hey again i super
appreciate everybody
who comes to these who everybody who
chats everybody who just watches along
in the background if you're not chatting
super appreciate you watching and uh
this community is
freaking awesome like you guys are
awesome uh you girls are awesome all the
girls in there
um every everyone everyone's awesome and
it's so cool like this is a really cool
time where we can do these watch parties
and things are releasing on disney plus
and you know we can watch these things
at home and we can watch them together
it's
you know it's way different than movies
just releasing in theaters so a really
weird
thing to kind of happen right out of
something bad like the pandemic but
you know and everything is unfortunate
but there's a
one good thing that has come out so you
guys are awesome
i will see you i'll do a video in about
five hours and next week
is the finale where we'll be back here
at it again so hope to see everybody
back here next week
again thank you to everybody for coming
out i'll see you next time woof